The Incredible Hulk is easily one of
Marvel's most recognizable characters
he's the big green guy with anger issues
now Marvel Studios is beefing up Bruce
banners role on their Cinematic Universe
with an arc that's set to play out over
the course of three movies starting in
Thor Ragnarok and continuing through the
next two Avengers films as for what
shape that arc might take that remains
to be seen but based on what we know we
can certainly make a few guesses some
spoilers ahead the story so far if
you're wondering why the Hulk's arc is
taking place in team-up pictures and
other heroes movies instead of a
standalone film it boils down to rights
issues as far as alt movies down on the
Hulk movie Marvel doesn't really have
the rights to that yet that's still
Universal property but at the same time
it also raises the question of whether
they'd actually want to angley's 2003
Hulk movie was to put it nicely a bit of
a mess and despite pulling off some
interesting visuals that play with
comic-book style panel layouts it's also
a movie that ends with a giant CGI
monster having a fistfight with a cloud
2008's Incredible Hulk starring Ed
Norton was equally messy a half reboot
half sequel that despite being the
second film in Marvel's shared universe
is also the one that nobody really
remembers or talks about Enter the
Avengers when the Hulk showed up in
2012's the Avengers however he was
definitely memorable
maybe that's why he was the focus of so
much of the sequel
despite being loaded up with new
characters age of Ultron was as much a
Hulk story as it was an Avenger story
he's the one who gets the romance angle
with Black Widow and who has the sad
ending of flying off to parts unknown in
the quintet kind of an amped-up
super heroic take on the TV shows
traditional ending with all that in mind
it's easy to assume the Hulk might just
work better in the context of stories
that feature other heroes which brings
us back around to Ragnarok Ragnarok and
Planet Hulk
according to Ruffalo Thor Ragnarok
kicked off his three movie arc and it's
easy to see where director Tycho ytt and
Marvel Studios got their starting point
Planet Hulk published from 2006 to 2007
Planet Hulk tells the story of Hulk
being stranded on an alien world that
for a little while at least zap some of
his strength he's forced to become a
gladiator and eventually leads a
revolution to overthrow the evil Red
King before returning to Earth and the
next phase of his adventures the entire
middle section of Ragnarok pulls heavily
from this story characters like Korg and
meek the planets a car in its brutal
contest and even Hulk's Roman inspired
gladiatorial gear are lifted directly
from the comics the only big difference
is that in the comics the Marvel
superhero who shows up for a guest
appearance as an opponent in the arena
isn't Thor it's the Silver Surfer so if
that's what we're working with now the
question is what's next infinity war
it's been clear for a while now that the
next Avengers movie infinity war will
draw the events of Infinity Gauntlet
which still stands as one of Marvel's
greatest crossover events but while
they've been ceding the infinity gems
throughout the MCU
the comic story they're building on
isn't actually all that Hulk heavy that
doesn't mean that the filmmakers
couldn't change things around and have
the Hulk play a bigger part in the same
way Ragnarok advanced the Hulk story by
combining Planet Hulk with pieces of
Walt Simonson's epic mid-80s run on Thor
we might be seeing a movie that mashes
up Infinity Gauntlet with another Hulk
story to create something new we just
need to figure out which one it might be
world war hulk there's one pretty
obvious follow up to the events of
Planet Hulk in the comics the events of
that story led directly to the next saga
world war hulk in which the hulk
returned from Sekar and beat the Dickens
out of well
everyone who he blames for setting him
to Sekar in the first place so will Hulk
turn on the other heroes
thanks to Ragnarok in the fight against
the Hulkbuster an age of Ultron we've
already seen how fun it can be to have
the Hulk Throwdown against the other
Avengers but there's one problem with
that story becoming the inspiration for
Hulk's arc in the movies Hulk isn't
tricked he boards the Quinn jet himself
as we've seen in Ragnarok the heroes of
the movies actually want banner around
if only so they can aim him at their
strongest enemies and let him go
so his things stand he doesn't have a
reason to be mad at the Avengers just
yet unless days of rage one comic that
might be a far more likely bit of source
material as days of Rage a senseless
shattering Throwdown that took place in
Incredible Hulk number 300 as the title
implies the basic idea of that issue is
that the Hulk goes into an unstoppable
rampage that finds him taking on the
entire roster of Avengers Plus
spider-man and Doctor Strange even
daredevil Luke Cage and iron fists make
cameo appearances although they're
pretty unlikely to show up in a movie
the centrepiece of the issue is a brutal
fight against Thor and it ends with
strange whisking the Hulk off into a
cosmic adventure
exactly the kind of thing that might get
him involved in a spacefaring battle
centered on the infinity gems Banner vs.
Hulk toward the end of Ragnarok Bruce
Banner turns back into the Hulk
presumably dooming himself to a
permanent life as a monster who can't
keep a pair of pants intact but what if
that's meant to set up an attempt to
cure banner by separating him from the
Hulk once and for all it's something
that's been done in the comics more than
a few times while he serves as a
two-fisted brick on the team Hulk's
entire deal as a solo character revolves
around a person dealing with himself
separating them would help to underline
that and a purely Raging Hulk would
certainly provide a unique cinematic
challenge the maestro of course if they
really wanted to focus on Bruce banners
dark side they could always introduce
the maestro an alternate future version
of the Hulk created by Peter David and
George Perez and future imperfect in
that story the core timelines banner
with his mind and control of the Hulk's
big green body heads off to an alternate
future where maestro is ruthlessly
conquered the world and brutally
dispatched every other superhero in the
Marvel Universe admittedly while the
x-men franchise has done it the MCU
movies haven't really messed around with
alternate timelines
that said it's not actually out of the
realm of possibility
evil opposites and dystopian futures are
standard tropes of the superhero genre
and since we're gearing up for a movie
that's focused on a set of rocks with
the power to control time and space it
could totally happen thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]